Gentlemen, this is
the dreaded bone chop.
This thing's a beast.
All I ever wanted to hear.
WIL WILLIS: The Yatagan.
The Yatagan was prominently
used by elite infantry
soldiers in Ottoman Turkey from
the 16th to 19th centuries.
Revered for its
extreme light weight
and lethal forward curve,
it was a quick and deadly
slicer, while its strong tapered
tip made it powerful thrust.
It also featured a unique yet
practical pommel that contained
flared out ears to
prevent it from slipping
from the hand of battle.
A fierce and respected
weapon, the Yatagan
was most notably
wielded by Suleiman
the Magnificent,
the longest reigning
sultan of the Ottoman Empire.
Bladesmiths, to see
what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do,
I'll take your Yatagan
and deliver slashes and thrusts
on this ballistics dummy.
Dave, you're first.
Are you ready?
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
I'm so nervous right now.
And I'm just hoping that
my blade will perform well.
[music playing]
She's got bowels
dripping out of her.
Let's talk about
your weapon, Dave.
It follows the feel of a
Yatagan that's supposed
to be light and deadly.
The edge you have here is sharp,
which curved in to lacerate.
Your Yatagan will kill.
Thank you very much.
All right, Gabe, your turn.
You ready?
Go nuts, man.
[music playing]
All right, Gabe,
it is so light,
it really feels
like it's not there.
It's almost scary.
When I thrust, it penetrates
easily and slashes down.
Overall, sir, your
blade will kill.
Thank you.
All right, gentlemen,
this is the strength test.
To test the strength
of your weapon,
I'll be chopping into
these bones six times.
Dave, you're up first.
Hacking bone is
a very difficult
thing to do with a thin edge.
I'm aghast knowing what's
going to be coming.
[music playing]
All right, David,
that's a tough test.
Those are very thick bones.
But what we've got going on
here is a lot of chipping
and distortion on your blade.
We've also got a major
crack in your handle that
runs right up through the pins.
All right, Gabe, your turn.
You're ready for this?
Go nuts.
[music playing]
OK, Gabe, the convex
edge you've got on here
is pretty much the perfect
edge for a test like this.
It's sharp and strong.
I can feel just the
smallest amount of a roll.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
All right, gentlemen,
next up, the sharpness test.
For that, I'll give you to Doug.
Bladesmiths, to see if
your blade is still sharp,
I will take your weapon and
slash through these silks.
If your blade is still
sharp, it should cut cleanly.
If not, it may rip or
tear or worse do nothing.
Dave, you're up first.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, I love the
balance of your blade.
I like the way it curves in.
But you can really
feel the edges now.
It's serrated.
It hangs up with silk.
But then on the last piece,
just when it's nice and taut,
it can lacerate
and cut through it.
Overall, your blade
will still cut.
Thank you.
All right, Gabe,
it's your turn.
You ready?
- I'm ready.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Gabe, your
blade is so light,
you're barely
cutting through air.
I glided through
this, lacerated,
and of course, in the
finishing cuts here,
cut easily through that silk.
It cuts.
Good job.
Thank you very much.
Bladesmiths, you both created
remarkable finale weapons.
But in this arena
of competition,
there can only be one
"Forged in Fire" champion.
And that champion is Gabe.
Congratulations, you are the
"Forged in Fire" champion.
Dave, please
surrender your weapon.
DAVE: It's exactly
what I expected.
It was very difficult
testing, but I'm
still the guy with the cracked
edge and the broken handle.
Gabe, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion
and will be receiving
a check for $10,000.
Good job.
I've never seen
anybody less stoked
about getting $10,000
in my entire life.
Why don't you please present
that weapon to the judges?
It feels great to be the
"Forged in Fire" champion,
but I'll do my celebrating
behind closed doors.
I felt like I was the
underdog, but underdogs
win sometimes I guess.
[music playing]
Holy [bleep].
WIL WILLIS: The Indian
two handed sword.
Emerging around the 17th
century, this rare two handed
sword joins some of the most
iconic bladed weapons produced
in the Indian subcontinent.
The long double edged blade
reached lengths of up to five
feet, and was so
heavy, it required
the wielder to use two hands
for more accurate strikes.
It also featured three brass
globes positioned on the shaft
that offered a more secure grip
as well as a counterbalance
for the heavy blade.
Despite its substantial size,
the blade was designed to flex.
By the mid-18th century,
improved gunpowder technology
spread throughout India,
making the Indian two
handed sword obsolete.
Bladesmiths, this
is the kill test.
To see what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do,
we'll take your sword
and deliver killing
blows on this boar carcass.
Jonathan, you're up first.
You ready?
Go for it.
[music playing]
All right, Jonathan, let's
talk about your sword right
here.
First up, it's sharp.
Definitely lacerated
through easily.
When wielding this weapon,
there's a nice balance to it.
Overall, your weapon,
sir, will kill.
Thank you.
Ed, are you ready?
I am.
[music playing]
All right, Ed, let's talk
about your weapon right here.
First up, I like the
leather wrapping that you
did right here on the handle.
It gives it a good grip.
Your blade is a little
bit on the heavier side.
But upon the swing, it lacerates
deeply into the carcass.
It will kill.
Gentlemen, this is
the dreaded bone chop.
Remember, this test
is all about what
the bones do to your
blades and not what
your blades do to the bones.
Ed, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Mm-hmm.
[music playing]
Well, Ed, it's
all in one piece,
but there is some chipping
on the blade here.
Oh, shoot.
The sword itself is heavy.
The handle is a bit
big for my hand.
All that being said, it
held up relatively well.
Well done.
- Thank you.
Jonathan, you're up.
Are you ready?
Hope so.
[music playing]
Well, Jonathan,
it's a similar result.
There is some edge
chipping here as well.
The handle being round on one
of the hits did roll in my hand.
Aside from edge chipping,
held up very well.
Well done.
Thank you.
All right, gentlemen, to test
the sharpness of your blade,
I'll be cutting
through these pumpkins.
We'll take a look at those cuts
and see how clean they are.
Jonathan, you're up.
Are you ready?
I'm ready.
[music playing]
So Jonathan, you can see, your
blade has such a flexibility
to it that when it hit,
the blade actually warped
that cut over and through.
It's a heck of a cutter.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
All right, Ed, you're up.
Are you ready?
[music playing]
All right, Ed, that's a good,
clean cut on that pumpkin.
You can kind of
see what happened.
I started compensating
for the weight
and pulled up and through.
The weight factor in me
using it is an issue.
But definitely sharp,
definitely a good cutter.
Well done.
It's really hard to say one
way or the other right now
who could and couldn't
win this thing.
Jonathan, Ed, the judges have
finished their deliberation,
and there can only be one
"Forged in Fire" champion.
And that champion is Jonathan.
Congratulations, you are our
new "Forged in Fire" champion.
Ed, your sword
didn't make the cut.
Please surrender your blade.
ED: I agree with the
judges' decision.
His blade was more usable.
I made a good blade, he made
a little bit better blade.
No matter what, I'm
still a happy cat.
Jonathan, good job.
You are our new "Forged
in Fire" champion.
And that's a title that comes
with a check for how much
money?
- $10,000.
$10,000, that's right.
Thank you.
Jonathan, please present
your blade to the judges.
I won "Forged in Fire"
and that's pretty awesome.
It's not really sunk
in yet that I won.
I'd love to have one
of those grinders,
so I might buy some
shop tools too.
We'll see.
[music playing]
J. Nielson's war scythe.
This war scythe was
personally created by our very
own beast from the East.
This war scythe is
a menacing variation
on a centuries old peasant's
weapon from Middle Age Europe.
Ready for battle at
a moment's notice,
farmers would take their
scythes from work to war
during uprisings, riots,
or calls to battle.
This weapon uses a long shaft
to generate massive power
to cut down enemies, while
its lethal sharp point
could be thrust into
infantry and cavalry.
This multifaceted
scythe features a fork
opposite the blade
as a piercing element
and a small blade at
the bottom of the pole
to finish off an opponent.
Scythes are represented
in pop culture
as sinister and ominous
weapons symbolizing death,
and is most notoriously
wielded by the grim reaper.
Up first, our very
own dealer of death,
the doer of deadly
deeds, the kill
test master, Doug Marcaida.
Yeah, he just looks
like a murderer.
I am really nervous.
[music playing]
All right, Alex,
the balance is light,
allowing it to be
a very fast weapon
that you can use either for long
handed or for close quarters.
Your weapon will kill.
All right, Trevor,
trick or treat?
Treat?
Indeed.
[music playing]
All right, Trevor, the tip alone
penetrates deeply into the gut,
and the edges here
are sharp enough to,
well, make it lose its head.
Overall, sir, it will kill.
Thank you, sir.
All right, smiths, welcome
to the strength test,
the dreaded coffin challenge.
I'm going to take these bones
and beat them repeatedly
into the blade of your scythes.
And Alex, you're locked
in and ready to go first.
You ready?
Yep.
That's what I want to hear.
[music playing]
Alex, you survived.
Good job.
The only issue I have, you
have some slight rolling
on the edge.
And the head of this moves,
so it's not secure anymore.
But your edge held up great.
Good job.
Thank you.
How you feeling, Trevor?
Pretty good right now.
Good.
We'll see how you
feel in a minute.
[music playing]
Nice job, Trevor.
Held up well.
Your edge is still
good, nice and sharp.
Everything's still tight.
Good job.
Thank you.
All right, bladesmiths,
this is the sharpness
test, the zombie surprise.
To test the edge of your weapon,
I'm going to take your scythe
and cut through this rope,
thereby releasing a surprise.
All right.
Alex, you're up first.
You ready?
Certainly.
[music playing]
All right, Alex, it
cut easily on the rope.
When you're puncturing this,
it cuts through and slices.
It'll cut.
Thank you.
All right, Trevor,
your turn, sir.
You ready?
Hell yeah.
[music playing]
All right, Trevor, the edge
that you have here lends itself
to cut the rope much easier.
When you're
puncturing, it starts
to cut all the way through.
Overall, sir, it will cut.
Thank you.
All right, bladesmiths, you
guys have done fantastic work,
but only one of you can be
the "Forged in Fire" champion,
and that champion is Trevor.
Congratulations, you are the
new "Forged in Fire" champion.
Alex, unfortunately, your
blade took some damage
in our strength test.
You did great work, my
friend, but at this time,
I have to ask you to
please exit the forge.
Ultimately, it came
down to the construction.
I think I definitely
made a blade
that can intimidate anyone.
Well, Trevor, the
judges all agree
you made a damn near perfect
war scythe which has earned you
the title of "Forged
in Fire" champion
and a check for $10,000.
Good job, brother.
Come on forward and
shake our hands.
I won!
Woo!
I think the biggest thing I
learned was to keep on trying.
If something doesn't go your
way, don't get upset about it.
Just keep moving forward.
This was a perfect
Halloween experience.
I feel like I just
went trick or treating
and I got a pillowcase
full of candy.
[music playing]
WIL WILLIS: Blackbeard's
infamous cutlass.
Among the most notorious
pirates of the 18th century,
Blackbeard terrorized
Caribbean and Atlantic
merchant shipping with his
trademark cutlass in hand.
Its short but thick curved blade
featured a razor sharp edge
that was ideal for hacking and
splashing during close quarters
combat while seizing
small vessels.
In his legendary battle with
Captain Robert Maynard in 1718,
Blackbeard's cutlass
broke Maynard's sword
in half with a single blow.
Today, Blackbeard's
menacing presence and expert
swordsmanship can still
be seen in the video game
"Assassin's Creed 4--
Black Flag."
Bladesmiths, to test the
lethality of your cutlass,
I'm going to inflict
lethal wounds
on these ballistic dummies.
Jason, you're up first.
You ready?
I sure hope so, Doug.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Jason, you've
got a very big handle here.
But at least it's
got the swells.
It's got an indexing for
where I hold on to it.
I can tell where the edge is.
The weight that you have in this
weapon is so light in the sense
that I can wield it,
even around here.
You've got the
clavicle, into the ribs,
all the way through the lungs,
and definitely, it will kill.
All I ever wanted to hear.
Made my day.
Seth, you're up next.
You ready?
Let's get some.
[music playing]
All right, Seth, your sword is
forward heavy without a balance
coming back.
I don't know whose shoulder
it's going to hurt more,
the dummy's or mine.
But your weapon, sir, will kill.
Thank you.
To test the strength and
durability of your swords,
I'll be chopping
through these bones
and then attacking that peg leg.
Now remember, this test is
not about what your blades
do to these targets.
It's about what these
targets do to your blades.
Jason, you're up.
Are you ready?
No.
[music playing]
The balance of your
weapon is really nice,
which is surprising
because you've
made a two handed cutlass.
Your blade held up very well,
except for the one little chip.
And it's not even a
chip, it's a roll.
So it didn't blow out.
It's a good job.
Thank you, Dave.
All right, Seth,
are you ready?
Yes, sir.
[music playing]
All right, Seth, first
up, this thing's a beast.
It is probably a pound heavier
than your competitor's sword.
Your blade, I mean, I can
run my fingernail down this,
and I can see a couple
of glinting spots,
but it really didn't
take any damage.
All right,
bladesmiths, let's find
out if there's any edge left.
This is the rope cut
and pirate sail slash.
To test the edge
of your cutlass,
I will cut this rope,
which will raise the sail,
and then I will slash the sail.
This is all about
what your sword
will do to the sail and rope.
Jason, you're up first.
Ready?
Yes, sir.
[music playing]
All righty, Jason, your edge
cut through the rope easily
and cuts with every
part that the edge
met on this pirate sail.
Overall, sir, your
sword will cut.
Awesome.
Seth, how are you feeling?
Feeling good.
Let's go.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Seth,
what are the chances
you find a very dull spot on
the first cut on the rope?
But on the second cut, it found
another spot that was sharp.
But on the sail, working
a heavy sword like this
affects my cuts.
Jason, Seth, the judges
have tested your weapons,
and they've made
a final decision.
Our new "Forged in
Fire" champion is Jason.
Congratulations, you're the
new "Forged in Fire" champion.
Seth, unfortunately, your
blade did not make the cut.
Please surrender your blade.
Jason, congratulations, you
are our new "Forged in Fire"
champion, and
that's a title that
comes with a bundle of
bullion that's worth $10,000.
How are you feeling right now?
I mean, come on,
that's incredible.
"Forged in Fire" champion?
[music playing]
The executioner's sword.
The executioner's sword
performed its bloody work
in 16th century Central Europe.
Unlike combat swords,
this lethal blade
features a straight double edged
cutting blade with a blunt tip,
perfect for swiftly chopping
off the heads of criminals.
This deadly weapon was used on
many aristocratic felons rather
than the ax, since
it allowed the victim
to meet his end in a
dignified kneeling position
rather than laying face down
with his head on the block.
While the executioner's
sword fell out of use
in the early 18th century,
this gruesome sword
is still wielded in the
2019 video game "Mordhau."
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the kill test.
The executioner's
sword, that word
alone just gives you visions
of decapitated heads.
So to find out what
kind of lethal damage
your executioner's sword can do,
I'll deliver some lethal blows
on this ballistics dummy.
Nathan, is it time?
It's time.
Have fun.
[music playing]
Holy crap.
Just a little off the top.
All right, Nathan, first
up, this is a heavy beast.
It is so forward heavy that you
need two hands to control that.
Now your handle
construction is smooth.
I'll give you that.
But it also feels a little
bit rounded over here,
where it actually gives
me much more control
sideways than it does this way.
But overall, your weapon,
sir, it will kill.
Awesome.
All right, Gunnar,
your turn, sir.
Are you ready?
- Absolutely.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Gunnar, let's
talk about your executioner's
sword over here.
Your blade right here
has a finer grind,
so it makes it a
little bit lighter.
And the edge that you have here,
when it came to that skull,
just glided into that.
Overall, sir, your executioner's
sword, it will kill.
Thank you.
All right, gentlemen, it's
time for the strength test,
the skull and bone chop.
To test the overall
construction of your blades
as well as how they feel
while they're being used,
I'll be chopping
into these skulls
and that nasty giraffe bone.
Nathan, you're up.
Are you ready?
Yes, sir.
Have fun.
[music playing]
Holy giraffe.
All right, Nathan, so right
off, man, this thing is heavy.
Once you get it moving, it's
going, but controlling it's
tough.
Having said that, your
edge held up beautifully.
It's still just as
sharp as when I started,
which is pretty darn sharp.
So good job on that.
Thanks, I like sharp things.
Gunnar, ready?
What if I said no?
I'd say [laughs] you don't
watch the show much do you?
Exactly.
[music playing]
All right, sir
Gunnar, right off,
lighter blade,
easier to control.
A lot of that has to do with
the fact that you've got more
handle here.
Now your blade, it's got
some compacting on the edges,
but I wouldn't run my
finger down this edge.
It's still bloody sharp.
Nicely done.
Thank you, sir.
All right,
bladesmiths, this is
the sharpness test, the
jackfruit and water jug slice.
Nathan, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Yes, sir.
Have fun.
All right, let's do this.
[music playing]
Still sharp.
All right, Nathan, as
far as the downward chop,
it's a very clean cut.
Easy, no resistance whatsoever.
Now, when I was
cutting, as soon as I
met the resistance of the water,
it kind of rolled on my hand.
But anything that it
did have contact with,
it was able to cut.
Overall, sir, your
weapon, it will cut.
Thank you.
All right, Gunnar,
your turn, sir.
You ready?
- Yes, sir, I am.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Gunnar,
the handle construction
you have here is
wide and ovoid enough
to wear when I hold
on to it, I can
really tell where the edge is.
It's much easier to
control a blade like this.
In the slice, you can
see that it cuts nicely.
Overall, sir, your
weapon, it will cut.
Thank you.
Bladesmiths, only one
of you can leave here
with the title of
"Forged in Fire" champion
and get that check for $10,000.
Now the judges
discussed your blades
and they made a final decision.
Today's "Forged
in Fire" champion
is Gunnar, congratulations.
Now Nathan, you fought
hard man, but unfortunately
your blade didn't make the cut.
I'm going to have to ask you
to step off the forge floor.
Thank you very much.
Congratulations.
Well, I'm going to have
to find a different way
to take my wife
to go see Bigfoot,
but we're still going to go.
Well, Gunnar, that makes you
the "Forged in Fire" champion.
You just got yourself
a check for $10,000.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
Appreciate it, guys.
I just won "Forged in Fire."
Feeling good?
I mean, I never
thought I would
make it this far from day one.
I don't necessarily think
that I'm a better smith
than any of these other guys.
It just worked out
in my favor today.
As far as the money, after
football season ends,
my wife and I will probably
take a long weekend somewhere.
[music playing]